how about we go for the dangerous
conversation the one that's going to get
us banned trying to be as careful as
possible
drugs junostar elliott page
announces he is transgender so this is
something that uh
came out earlier look i'm fairly
libertarian so if somebody you know
is trans or whatever and they want to be
called whatever i i have absolutely no
problem and more power to them they can
live their life be happy and do all that
stuff
but uh when you're talking about you
know the democrats and take going after
this woke you know giving them the woke
things they want
talking about social media censorship
and stuff like this we're in we're in
dangerous territory
talking about these issues i'll just
i'll come out right come right out and
say it
there was a website um dedicated to
stories about de-transitioning
from people who came out as trans got
you know uh
it's it's it's look it's all part of the
woke you know critical gender theory
stuff
and there are people telling their story
saying they were pressured into it
pressured into life-altering surgeries
or taking medications
and all of these posts get banned from
reddit
these forums where people are talking
about are banned from reddit
conversations like the one we're having
now like i said it's dangerous because
they could ban me for it
and that's crazy because if the internet
only allows if these big tech companies
only allow conversation that's
it's good it's good it's always good no
matter what then all
anyone will ever hear is how good it is
and they won't hear that look in life
sometimes things aren't good
and i'm not saying what you know elliot
page is doing is not is good or bad i'm
just saying
you need to have a balanced and healthy
view analyzing all of these you know
different subjects and what people are
saying
in one way or another but when we start
to have the mass censorship
on social media conversations that can't
happen
can't talk about covet in a certain way
they'll ban you in two seconds can't
talk about masks can't report on
studies about masks they'll ban you then
what ends up happening is you develop a
society that
has a skewed and warped view on many
different subjects
so now we we're ending up with and i'm
not trying to direct any
you know eye or anything towards elliot
page for those
those aren't familiar it's it i might
get banned for this because it's called
dead naming but elliott page
formerly ellen page no joke it's it's
it's it's like
that that difficult to talk about this
stuff without because youtube will come
down and they'll and they'll nuke you
immediately
so i uh had a personal uh interaction
actually multiple personal interactions
with
um with mr page uh
uh on several occasions uh
because we were for a while neighbors uh
really
yeah lived uh very close to each other
um and
uh at times in fact uh i think twice
i conversed with and bought drinks for
uh mr page without even knowing it so i
i think that now
i should be at least earn allyship for
that because i had no idea how
progressive i was being in the moment
but in retrospect i was being very very
reaching out we actually talked about
mike pence at the time yes
but uh wonderful wonderful actor
and uh i'm sure that you know there are
a lot of trans roles now
that you know people say trans people
should be the only people who are
allowed to play them
obviously that's something that scarlett
johansson ran into a couple of years ago
had to drop a role and cancel the entire
movie yeah so definitely going to be i
think uh some productive opportunities
for
uh mr page i think elliott is an amazing
human
um regardless of sex or gender or
whatever and i think that it's important
that we can talk about
sex and gender and like he and she and
him and them and they
and all that crap like it you know like
normal
like we have to talk about that yeah you
have to have it you have to be able to
have conversations about this stuff yeah
well but that's impossible in a
situation where government comes in
or corporate america comes in and
basically says you
you have to be walking on eggshells
because you use
you might use the wrong pronoun yeah and
especially when you have this fiction
this idea that the internet has embraced
that suddenly as soon as someone makes
that change in their life
there's a refusal of any kind of
admission that this change
happened and to me it's it's not like
i don't know i i just think that this is
a situation where you you have to be
able to talk about it openly without
fear of repercussions as you see in
places like canada well so there there's
a
a big part of the story which um what we
i think we can
do yes we have is that in the uk there's
a ruling that effect that essentially
says
under 16s can't get puberty blockers so
you need you need to have these
conversations
because it's not like i think leftists
don't realize this
maybe because they're too young but
think about pot legalization which is
happening across the country
the only reason it's happening is
because people were smoking it illegally
and they knew they liked it and the
conversation started happening around
legalizing it which means a bunch of
criminals were getting together
committing crimes
and deciding hey it shouldn't be a crime
anymore and then a bunch of states were
like
that's actually a good point we
shouldn't be if everybody said you can't
do it you'll go to jail you'll be banned
your life will be ruined
we would never have it so that means you
have to have calm
rational reasonable conv reasonable
conversations but i'll bring up a couple
points
that i think are a a serious problem for
us in society based on the things we're
seeing with elliott page and again
not directing any duration at elliot
specifically but
wikipedia for instance is is is
widely used one of the most popular
sites in the world has very serious
problems notably
you can't use twitter or social media of
an individual as a source
yet in every circumstance where an
individual comes out as trans the moment
they tweet
the wikipedia editors all change
everything as though that's a legitimate
source what if you were hacked
and someone tweeted something and they
changed your wikipedia because of this
it also creates a very strange
circumstance uh somebody tweeted
something
where it said uh in reference to elliot
page in 2008 he
was named the 93rd sexiest woman alive
so it it's and i'm not saying again you
know i'm trying to be careful i'm not
trying to be mean or disrespectful
it creates very confusing circumstances
that people outside of the woke bubbles
will have no idea what's going on or
what this means so when you talk about
it well real quick
the reason i bring that up is that if
you go to somebody who's maybe like you
know
not super active on the internet which
is most people and you
you read them that line they would
assume it was a gag
they would be like oh like borat or
something right like if borat won an
award for being a sexy woman they
wouldn't realize
that you know elliot was previously
ellen that there's you know there's an
issue here
these things haven't been worked through
our society hasn't
had it i'll put i'll put it this way
these things have
have seemingly just blinked into
existence to the average person
we don't know what this means we don't
know how to interact but they're banning
us they're coming for our jobs they're
threatening our careers because of it
i would think like if you talked about
the past of someone that transitioned
that you would use the
old pronoun if you're talking about that
time when they used to be the old
pronouns
people can change their names all the
time and it doesn't confuse people
i guess that's it's kind of like
changing your name but but i just think
that people
living in this fictional world just
makes for all
the the demands i think that it places
on people who are not
very online and i mean you know imagine
someone who tomorrow
you know picks up juno and says some
compliment about paige's performance
and then gets accused of you know dead
naming
and and you know not respecting etcetera
but this this
this will happen yeah so someone who is
not very online might tweet
just watch juno ellen page she was
fantastic and then they're going to get
attacked
they're going to get they're going to
get banned they're going to get
suspended on twitter
you i remember uh zooby remember zooby
first of all zooby
identifying as a woman and then broke
the deadlift record to make a point
but then tweeted someone in on twitter
okay dude
got suspended yeah and and because but
it was like an informal colloquial okay
dude
look they're coming for gina carano from
the mandalorian oh right because of
putting
uh beep bop boop or whatever in here
instead of the the pronouns were they
were they were forcing her to put
pronouns in
no she was she was getting yelled at for
not doing it that's like some c16
canadian jordan peterson speaking right
right forced compelled speech
jordan peterson warned us but listen
it's not the government doing it
it's private corporations oh you're
going to make me cry just mentioning its
name
jordan so oh did you not see the
the employees oh
so much about the story was that they
thought that that was a story they
needed to tell
to the reporter like this is going to
help us it's going to
show how i heard they were going to
publish a jordan peterson book and i
cried and it's like
my question is what was the book about i
don't know he's
always right or something cooking jordan
peterson family recipes
and it's nothing but steak yes just take
every page
i love this idea that's a great idea i
was thinking about sex and gender about
how okay when i was raised i was taught
that sex and gender are different they
are
that sex is your bio biology and gender
is what you identify with the most
gender is is uh social social social is
how you socially identify
no no like words can have gender so in
romance languages words are gendered
so why not just acknowledge whatever sex
you are
okay but then if you want to change your
gender just go legally do it at a
at the courthouse no no no no why not
that would be so easy no no no no
i'm sorry your id doesn't say man or
woman it says male or female and the
reason for that is typically medical or
for leak important and that's it you
legal add something to the
identification if you wanted to use a
different gender this is this is the
issue that's really causing everything
to kind of break down is that
you're correct uh sex and gender are
different things typically
for the longest time especially with me
growing up people use sex and gender
interchangeably
right but uh if someone comes out and
says it's a distinction i can say
absolutely fine no problem
the issue is though on your passport on
your id on your birth certificate it
says male or female
not to make you feel better not to
express your identity
but to explain to people medically what
you
likely are it's not perfect but i i
we we i did a segment on this for for
scanner which is the the news outlet now
emily rocco are running we talked with
dr deborah soh
and we she's wonderful she's wonderful
she's she's a she's brilliant
and in it we talk about the 1992 i
believe health revitalization act
before this 1992 get this not even that
long ago
when they did clinical trials they had
no obligation to actually
do clinical trials on both males and
females and so what ended up happening
was
medication would come out that would be
particularly ineffective or dangerous
for females when you do when there's
when there's a medical emergency there's
a reason why
there's a male or female on your id it's
not just so that when you show your id
someone can see this and then call you
by your proper pronouns
it's so that if you fall down and
they're like what medication can we give
this person
they have a better idea now in most
circumstances most times someone's in a
medical emergency male or female they're
going to be able to help you out just
fine
but there are circumstances where for
distinct reasons
it's important that we understand your
biology is not you can have like
it's a male she her like if you wanted
to go to the courthouse and get your
gender legally changed
but still have that it says male so if
there's a medicine that it's dangerous
for feminism i just think that a lot of
this
gets into the nitty-gritty of the way
that that uh you know government
and corporations have to define
everything about us at all times and
it's just it's
it's a very difficult thing but just to
go back to the original point you made
the the page story um and
again as as an actor great uh
uh umbrella academy was good you know
the uh great next men
uh yeah and incredible um and i just
think that
part of the problem is you you put these
two stories next to each other the uk
story and the
and the uh page story and then this
other piece that got written
this past week uh perhaps i i don't know
how she knew this story was coming
by uh katie herzog from uh who
does blocked and reported with jesse
single the podcast which you should uh
listen to
she wrote this piece this amazing piece
about uh called uh
where where are all the lesbians gone uh
that
uh talked about the fact early on that
they're like only 15 lesbian bars left
in america
and that all these people are redefining
themselves as trans instead of lesbian
it's it that's crazy look at this uh
katie writes lesbian bars have always
been vastly outnumbered by bars for
straight people and gay men
but but in the 1980s there were more
than 200 lesbian bars in the us
what happened well a lot of them sucked
the first lesbian bars i went to in my
early 20s were dank smokey caves where
women in khaki shorts and backward caps
grinded on each other to outcast
they could have been fret bars if not
for the notable absence of men
uh and she i don't know if she
specifically references 15 or whatever
she says there's also
economic challenge this is what took
down lexington and infamous
i can't use that word unfortunately on
youtube um but yeah
she goes on to say there used to be a
lot more and that was kind of the point
i want to bring up
she the the point that she's overall
making is that something is happening
here
in society and the problem that you're
pointing out is that
basically if we move into the way that
certain people want us to talk about
this
we can't even discuss it we can't even
you know kind of put it out on the table
and say well let's talk about this
interesting phenomenon
why is it happening and to me that's
just it's just so
we got to talk to she she literally
opens with whoops click the wrong thing
she literally opens with opens with
there are only 15 lesbian bars left in
the entire country
it's crazy so there are are you familiar
with get the l out
this was a protest in i believe in the
in the uk
many of these uh lesbians are being
called you know turfs
they were basically saying that trans
activism is erasing
lesbians and this is kind of what i
guess katie herzog is saying about the
lesbian bars
i just think that this is a situation
where it's almost impossible to discuss
all of these things honestly if we have
the kind of restrictions
that are trying to be put up it's crazy
and that's crazy especially with that uk
case that is going to lead to
a ton more lawsuits what was the case oh
yeah so high court ruling on puberty
blockers protects
teenagers says women who sued nhs three
judges say children under 16 must be
able to give their competent consent
and understand the treatment so this was
a
a woman who transitioned and then
realized it was
for them a mistake and then
de-transition de-transitioned
but i tell you you can't have that
conversation there like i mentioned
there was a website that told all these
stories i'll tell you man
some of the most horrifying stories and
the reason why they were horrifying is
that they were saying their loved ones
were just telling them
do it do all of these things and they
weren't getting an
honest healthy therapeutic and
and loving analysis of what was going on
in their lives and what they really
needed to feel better they were kids
they were people it was it was stories
of all types stories of all types and uh
there were there were forums on reddit
that talked about this they like reddit
you know subreddits where they were like
here's here's what what i went through
banned all banned and then mario lopez
comes along and says you shouldn't be
shoving drugs into kids
and suddenly has to go through this
mario mario lopez said three-year-olds
probably don't know if they're trans and
he had to apologize for it so who
he was going to get fired i guess by who
i mean listen
mario you shouldn't have apologized
absolutely not when i was three i
probably wanted to be a triceratops yeah
joe biden said if an eight-year-old
decides to be trans there should be no
discrimination
i used to play as wonder woman i used to
dress up not dress up but i would run
around be like i'm wonder woman she was
my favorite character so i'd
but i i didn't want to be a woman i was
always like what would it be like to be
a girl i mean it's just crazy
i thought but so so this is what happens
joe biden when he said that if an
eight-year-old chooses to be trans it
should be no discrimination
that is the kind of i believe that's
irresponsible i believe the correct
answer should be
the issues of private family matters for
minors is the responsibility of their
parents and their doctors
mm-hmm that's it yeah he shouldn't be
telling or encouraging or saying no no
listen
there are there are certainly
circumstances where there are
transgender kids and teenagers and the
parents need to make sure they're doing
everything right and the doctors are
doing everything right he's so checked
out
when he did that at the debate and told
that woman about her eight-year-old
yeah the town hall yes yeah yeah but but
but that again is the sinkhole that you
just get sucked into on these things
where where logic goes out the window
and you don't think about the
ramifications of it
and then you wake up one morning and
there are a bunch of kids who need
therapy
and are pissed off at their parents for
shoving drugs into them for something
there was that uh that viral clip from i
think that hbo show
where the the young trans kid telling
his mom
my life is ruined i hate this i
shouldn't have ever done it
and the mom just stares and says nothing
and it's almost like
you know it goes back into what i was
saying about censorship the fact that
even having this conversation we run the
risk of getting demonetized and getting
banned but it needs to be talked about
um if this mother never heard any of
these conversations
then the only thing she knew was must be
good now now the kid is telling his mom
and this is on hbo this is going viral
my life is ruined i can't stand it
parents need to be there for their kids
man this is just i mean it's
it's a tragedy and the adults
who i think we will look back on this as
being
a very stupid and crazy time for the
kind of adults
who just egged all of this on and acted
as if there were no downsides
you know science can solve your problems
for you and make all the
confusion go away when kids are confused
and teenagers especially are confused
and we should let people work their way
through these things and make decisions
as informed adults
and not force them into boxes early on
based on you know what you've read in
the in the
silly magazines that make for make
arguments for dean vogue
yes and stuff like that and
you know that one of the issues is uh i
think there's a kind of a feedback
loop that is driving the left insane so
they make rules to appease what they
think is normal
then those rules create an environment
where you can only talk about what they
think is normal
which then slowly starts spinning and
spinning and moving further and further
left so
you end up with the ceo of twitter
saying here's our rules
and the rules are applicable or
understood only by eight percent of the
population the ultra progressives
regular people are being banned left and
right creating an echo chamber of all
this far left nonsense
which then results in people growing up
getting jobs at twitter and then
believing the insane nonsense and then
enacting rules
of what they think is normal and it's an
endless segment and that's why the
future
of the left depends on the line that
runs through aoc's heart
because she as someone who is a
legitimate economic progressive
and a populist i believe on those points
had
has shunted those issues to the side in
order to
accept and embrace this woke
ridiculousness
and you know a byproduct of that she and
the rest of the squad pushing bernie
into that box which
he had never occupied before
historically he had you know talked
about
you know race as you being used by you
know corporations to divide us
in ways where that we should be united
based on class interests
and economic interests until 2016. until
yes and then he went woke and then and
then we have a situation where
you know the the left now are you just
going to be satisfied with a situation
where facebook is policing this stuff
and youtube is banning tim poole and you
know you have big tech doing all these
different things carrying out your woke
agenda meanwhile you know the very class
people you've always said you were
fighting for against
the amazons of the world are getting
absolutely crushed
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you